hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar human certified omics data to
power drug discovery this webinar is
part of the fifth annual drug discovery
and development
virtual conference and i am susie valdez
of lab roots and i will be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots and sponsored by kyogen for
more information about our sponsor
please visit them at www.kyogen.com
now before we begin i want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to first participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our new live
chat feature during the presentation you
can find that live chat located at the
right of your screen you can also
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
and if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation just click on
the help desk button located at the
bottom of your screen within the
navigation bar or from the lobby and
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits just click
on the continuing education credits link
located in the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits i now
present today's speaker dr joseph
pearson a global product manager at
kyogen digital insights for complete
biography of our speakers please visit
the biography tab at the left of your
screen dr pearson welcome you may now
begin your presence
my name is joseph pearson i am the
global product manager for omicsoft part
of kyogen digital insights
i will be talking today about why high
quality human certified data is really
essential for bioinformatics and data
science and drug discovery
before i begin i'll point out that the
kyogen products i mentioned are intended
for molecular biology applications
not for the diagnosis prevention
or treatment of a disease
now whether you are detecting subtle
signatures for disease
tissue
cell type or treatment response
or identifying new candidate indications
that are relevant to your target pathway
you need data that are precisely
relevant to the question you are asking
maybe you just need a strong reference
data set of normal and disease ohmic
signatures to compare against your
internal data
with rapidly growing public data
available for many diseases a common
approach is to utilize these resources
integrating different data sets to try
to generate a more robust signal
these data sets come from large
consortium projects like
tcga gtx
human cell landscape as well as from
thousands of data sets related to
individual published works to be found
in array express geo and sra
you also may have internal data sets
that can shed light
a key problem is that these data sets
must be discovered
unified
and centralized
to harness the value of the larger data
set for meta analysis
which uses
significant time
money and resources
without extensive unification and
centralization these data cannot be
easily discovered and explored by
biologists
bioinformaticians and data scientists
and you frequently end up with just a
small amount of usable data
and sometimes just a pile of useless
excel files
the goal of data science is to reveal
subtle patterns that aren't apparent by
looking variable by variable gene by
gene etc
the problem is
that it takes a tremendous amount of
time to whip data into the right shape
to perform real data science
in order to deeply analyze individual
data sets or
to analyze across multiple related data
sets to reveal consistent patterns you
need clean data
first
you need to find the data download the
data process and normalize the omix
experiments and then you need to
retrieve the metadata files that
describe each sample which may be in one
or multiple files and match these to the
omix experiments
you also need to
make sure that you understand the
meaning of each metadata field
clear definition of the metadata is even
more critical if you are integrating
multiple data sets because bad
unification
of data sets with mismatched metadata
fields will lead to bad interpretations
only after you spent way too much time
cleaning and organizing
the data from individual data sets then
unifying across the data sets can you
get to the interesting problems
looking for the patterns in the data
refining your algorithms to reveal the
patterns and testing the value of the
patterns with training sets and so forth
now there's a second related problem
clean metadata are essential to
capturing the biological relevance but
bioinformaticians and data scientists
are often focused on the task of
cleaning the omics data themselves
and they don't have the biological
perspective to capture the crucial
metadata so the individual data sets may
be properly analyzed but as far as
integrative analysis you frequently end
up with folders full of excel files that
really aren't much use
now what if data scientists could skip
over the time consuming data retrieval
and curation tasks and spend more time
on data science
with access to highly clean
consistent data
data scientists can skip over the time
consuming tasks of cleaning data
and avoid the pitfalls of poorly
cleaning metadata and get right to the
task of hunting for patterns across the
data
these same data can be used as a
repository to pull individual data sets
discoverable by biomarker signatures or
by metadata fields with clean
definitions and ontologies
whether looking for patterns across data
sets or hunting for the specific data
set that will answer your question
the biologists that you work with get
their answers quickly so they can design
the next set of experiments
given the huge amount of data available
it's tempting to aggregate all the data
through a huge automated pipeline omix
data can be run through an automated
pipeline or the pre-analyzed data can be
normalized after the fact
metadata can be integrated and
harmonization of metadata can be
achieved by automatically applying
ontologies or
natural language processing
this approach isn't bad when integrating
a couple of large consortium data sets
and if you are only interested in the
main sample metadata fields like tissue
and disease
because chances are good that a common
and recognizable ontology is being used
and the cleaning is simple enough
but
as you increase the number of data sets
to integrate or try to integrate more
data types or unify and interpret more
metadata fields like clinical parameters
treatment history
the applicability of automated methods
will quickly run out
the alternative to relying on automated
data integration is data that had been
curated and reviewed by scientists
humans with specific domain expertise
the ability to make judgments on
ambiguous data and iterate on the
curation processes with a plan to future
uses
this results in higher quality data with
lower error rates so downstream analysis
goes more smoothly
greater flexibility to integrate newer
data types and data structures
and greater flexibility in capturing and
structuring relevant metadata such as
from images and from full text
now the curation protocols can also be
designed with fair principles in mind
helping to make the data findable
accessible
interoperable and reusable
these are the goals
that we've had in mind over
our 25 years experience a quarter of a
century curating data and biomolecular
knowledge with curation now performed by
over 200 curation experts as part of
kaijan digital insights
to ensure highest quality kaijen has
developed detailed protocols for
curation of biomedical relationships
multi-omics data
and gene variant data
to consistently capture
the relevant information
causal biomedical relationships are
curated from biological findings from
publications such as molecule to
molecule as well as molecule to disease
function and localization
molecular pathways
and findings about regulators and
targets drugs and disease biomarkers
sample level ohmics data from disease
relevant
consortia and thousands of published
projects are carefully curated with
extensive controlled vocabularies and
curation rules apply across data sets to
maximize intercomparability
and the largest most up-to-date resource
for peer-reviewed gene variation data
linked to disease for both somatic and
hereditary mutations as well as
real-world data with observed variations
and we think that it's this dedication
to well-structured human-centered
curation that provides higher quality
starting points for data science
in fact if you would like to learn more
about some of the key lessons that we've
learned from our experience
we presented seven habits of good manual
curation
presented with the pistol alliance
and you can find this presentation
online at the postoya alliance website
and you can also find these seven habits
on the kaijan digital insights youtube
channel just search for kayajin manual
curation
for the remainder of this webinar i'm
going to focus on the kaijan digital
insights curated omix datasets which are
found in our omicsoft land databases
to date
cayegian curators has spent over 60
thousand hours of manual curation effort
to clean up thousands of
disease-relevant data sets found in
repositories like geo and array express
and large consortia like tcga gtx and
ccle
resulting in databases with over 650 000
samples ready for data science
applications
over the many years of experience
curating data sets and working with our
customers to define and refine curation
rules
we have established curation standards
to enable consistency within and across
data sets
making the data ready for revealing
deeper insights
our bioinformaticians
use consistent data analysis pipelines
to process the input data to make the
data sets more consistent and
cross-comparable
analyzed on standardized genomes and
gene models
and our statisticians use the
extensively curated sample metadata to
carefully model statistical comparisons
for studies to reveal the differential
gene expression signatures
and these data are available
as full flat file exports of the entire
databases which can be used by data
scientists for large-scale analyses and
these same data can be interactively
explored through our software sliced and
diced by bioinformaticians to find the
most relevant data sets for exploratory
work and prioritizing candidate
biomarkers
and these data are really great for
quickly answering biologist questions
like
is my gene expressed in a specific
tissue disease
cell type is it up or down regulated
after
treatment or is it higher in treatment
resistant patients
these questions can be answered using
our data quickly and confidently because
of the detailed manual curation and the
size of the curated databases
our curated omix data sets continue to
grow every quarter with data sets
representing hundreds of diseases in
oncology
and non-oncology disease
as well as expression in normal tissue
and cell lines and new single cell
transcriptomic data with the same depth
of manual curation as with our bulk
lands
so how do we know
that our depth of curation our extensive
curation and formatting rules and
ontologies is improving the value of the
data
firstly
our curators need to hunt down the
relevant metadata that are scattered
across data submissions supplementary
data and tables in the publication
and they also frequently see that the
data as they are submitted have mistakes
that cannot always be caught by
automated processes
in our experience
about 35
of data sets that our curators review
include typos in the metadata describing
the cell lines and treatments and so
forth
but about five percent of the time the
data are just not interpretable without
getting feedback from the authors
because during the review
we discover inconsistent terms
mislabeled treatments infections and so
forth
inconsistent sample groupings between
the data submission and the publication
and errors in the subject id to sample
id mapping
and so we are routinely contacting the
authors to clarify these inconsistencies
to make sure that we have the highest
quality data possible
so as one recent example
a project that
our curators were working on was
focusing on clinically significant
genetic differences between subtypes of
bcp acute lymphoblastic leukemia
thank you again dr pearson for your time
today and for your important research
and before we go i want to thank our
audience for joining us for today and
i'd also like to thank our sponsor
kaijin for sponsoring today's webinar
questions submitted today and during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
for two years until february 2024.
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for a replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone